he was supposed to be his queen
we're not going to hold it back any
longer Queen Lea we have a message for
you and we mean business
can you just leave Audrey alone she was
obviously under a whole lot of stress
when she chose to steal the Queen's
crown and clearly you're the one to
blame for her villainous breakdown if
there's one thing that everyone noticed
it's that you're the real villain of
descendant 3 well Queen Lea was busy
trying to control her granddaughter's
life we got busy with spotting out 10
things everyone missed in d3 keep
watching to find out why Audrey was able
to touch Maleficent scepter without
getting cursed Hades tells all we had no
idea that now knew who her father was
but what was even more shocking was
finding out that Hades and Maleficent
were actually married once upon a time
nidia tells all during his
father-daughter duet saying that it
wasn't easy being married to mouths
mother we didn't know that weddings
happened on the Isle of the Lost
so this rapid-fire fact caught us by
surprise Audrey treats Chadd like a dog
the way Audrey treats Chad proves what
most of us already knew
Audrey has zero feelings for
Cinderella's son but when it comes to
Chad it's easy to see that he would
follow Audrey to the end of the world
Audrey treats Chad like the lovesick
puppy that he is she even stroked his
hair like the top of a dog's head
but then again Chad didn't seem to mind
the Sleeping Beauty reference Queen Leah
throw some serious shade her
granddaughter's way as soon as Malin
then get engaged
she tells Audrey she isn't exactly wrong
after all
Audrey's mother is Sleeping Beauty so
this statement is totally accurate mini
Audrey and Ben getting dumped is never
easy which is why most of us feel for
Audrey but we felt her heartache even
more when we glanced around her dorm at
auradon prep Audrey had plenty of
pictures of her and Ben around her room
and we spotted one frame which showcased
Ben and Audrey as little kids
this means that Ben was Audrey's first
love ever since she was a little girl
now that is just heartbreaking
living conditions it's hard to believe
that the people of auradon eat
scrumptious meals day in and day out
while the people of the Isle pick flies
out of their baked goods the Isles
living conditions are downright awful
just ask the VKS
poor Gil had never even tried a grape
before or picked fresh berries from a
bush the BK's definitely deserved to be
spoiled from here on out
dude the talking dog another thing we
noticed in d3 is that dude the dog was
still able to talk this sort of confused
us since dude could only speak because
he ate a truth gummy so wouldn't you go
back to barking after a day or two that
is unless mal made Carlos an endless
supply of truth gummies so that he could
continue chatting with his best but the
Maleficent reference when Queen Leah
refused to invite Maleficent to her
daughter's christening the villain went
bonkers and well the same can be said
about Audrey she totally embodies
Maleficent when she crashes Jane's
birthday party before putting everyone
to sleep cleanliness truth queen Liam
might be the evilest grandmother that
ever lived but that doesn't mean that
she doesn't genuinely care about Audrey
Leah looked super distressed when Audrey
was unconscious in her bed despite
hating villains Leah let Hades used his
amber on Audrey's which saved her life
this led to mal wanting to open the
barrier once and for all but unlike
everyone else Leah looks super angry
when mal took down the barrier Jane's
birthday cake
Jane's birthday cake looked absolutely
delicious which is why Celia and Izzy
stole a piece before Carlos could get
the cake to Jane but Celia and Izzy
weren't the only ones who ate a piece of
Jane's cake was it just us or was this
cake never-ending everyone kept cutting
out huge pieces but somehow there was
always enough cake to go around parry
hook wants a girlfriend
we love Harry hook he's suave sleek and
everything we could ever want in a
pirate but as it turns out harry wants
more from life than being umas first
mede was it just us or was Harry
desperately trying to find himself a
girlfriend from uma to Jane to Audrey
it's clear that Harry wants a first mate
of his own we owe you an apology
at the end of the film now Audrey and
then all managed to bury the hatchet now
and ventilatory that they owe her an
apology but funny enough they never say
I'm sorry out loud it looks like Malin
then need to brush up on their auradon
manners but in the end we're just happy
that Audrey came back to her senses a
glowing dragon I when Audrey breaks into
the museum it's clear that she's only
after the Queen's crown but that's when
something strange happens well if it's
in scepter drag and I start gluing a
vibrant green and calling Audrey over to
it and on top of that Audrey doesn't get
cursed for 1,000 years after grabbing it
the only explanation we can think of is
that dragon I was bored and sensed
Audrey's anger and sadness making her
someone he could easily turn into a
villain did you guys notice anything
that we didn't sound off in the comments
section wait Audrey stop
don't use that I thought you liked it
spells mistakes happen don't they Audrey
we don't mean to single you out but we
feel like you to understand where we're
coming from you probably didn't notice
any inconsistencies when you were trying
to take over auradon but we spotted
dozens of them and we're about to reveal
them one by one but don't worry these
mistakes won't ruin your reputation in
any way like many other movies
descendants 3 has a handful of mistakes
that can be both easy and challenging to
spot we're about to reveal them all so
keep watching
do you like Prince mouth
how about a knight in shining armor One
Nights the basket of pears the queen of
mean acts on impulse if she gets mad she
curses whoever offended her and if she
wants answers to questions whoever is
next to her she always gives them what
she thinks she deserves chad charming
might be a follower but he never
betrayed Audrey's trust right before
Audrey locks Chad in a closet she
questions him and throws a glass bowl at
his head but before she does this she
empties out the pear bowl on the table
at first there's a total of five pairs
on the table but when the camera cuts
back to Audrey there are only three
pairs left
Dizzy's outfits at the very beginning of
d3 the villain kids put on quite the
show alongside the corpore they dance do
wicked acrobatics and show off their
true colors despite showing us some
awesome moves something bizarre happens
to dizzy during this musical number
we Percy dizzy wearing a long dress made
out of patchwork but then a few seconds
later we see her wearing an entirely
different outfit how did dizzy managed
to switch outfits so quickly this is the
most fashionable mistake we've ever seen
mouth powers another mistake we couldn't
help but notice has everything to do
with mouth when Hades tries to escape
through the barrier then Jay and Carlos
try to stop him but he blasts them with
his Ember
this causes mal to transform into a
dragon and take on her dear old dad but
Hades ends up blasting her too and
according to mal he was draining all of
her powers so why you think that Mouse
powers didn't take a hit throughout the
film this is more of an inconsistency
than a mistake but it's puzzling
nonetheless the security guard another
inconsistency we couldn't help but
notice occurs when Audrey goes to the
Museum of cultural history Audrey
doesn't have any magical powers of her
own yet somehow she manages to put the
guard to sleep with zoom on the loose we
find it very unlikely that the guard
chose to take a snooze
Audrey obviously put the guard to sleep
before cutting the security cameras but
how
did she do this it just doesn't make any
sense she also opened the museum space
without laying a finger on them protect
the crown not the sceptre but Audrey's
magical touch isn't the only strange
thing that happens at the Museum
everything from the Queen's crown to
Cinderella's glass slippers two genies
lamp is protected by security glass but
when it came to Maleficent scepter
nothing was shielding it from Audrey's
grass this is super off-putting
considering the scepter is a super
dangerous weapon James birthday cake
descendants three managed to make us
feel an array of emotions and one of
those was jealousy who else wanted to
grab a piece of Jane's birthday cake but
couldn't well you're not alone
luckily dizzy and Celia were able to
steal a piece from Jane's birthday cake
before Carlos had the chance to give it
to her we clearly see that a single
piece of cake is missing but when the
camera cuts to dizzy and Celia eating
cake they each have their own piece and
plate so why is it that there was only
one piece missing from the cake the
cupcake once audrey gets her hands on
the crown in the scepter she doesn't
waste any time she crashes Jane's party
and starts picking on everyone in her
path does that make you sad does it just
ruin everything
she even craps a cupcake out of
someone's hands and throws it away now
that's just cruel where we the only ones
who notice that Audrey grabbed the
cupcake backwards and yet didn't have
any frosting on her hand once you
chucked it tell us if you noticed this
mistake in the comments below
watch your back Carlos do you like a
prince mal how about a knight in shining
armor twenty Knights one of our favorite
scenes from descendants three is the
metal knight fight this is when the BJS
truly learn how to work together at one
point during the fight Carlos loses his
sword there's a knight right above him
who's ready to strike so Celia saves the
day by sliding a shield Carlos is way
but for some strange reason the knight
never strikes Carlos Willis puts the
shield up that nothing happens then he
slides away on it was this a huge
mistake on the Knights part VK day is
here we all know that mal is a talented
spray paint
but during the good to be bad musical
number we see mal making a huge mistake
she's supposed to be spray-painting BK
Day on the door of a barn but it just
didn't look believable clearly mal was
just pretending to spray-paint old hag
now Audrey may be a lot of things but
humorless is not one of them
she turns mal into an old hag at the
beginning of d3 you think Ben will love
you now you old hag forcing mal and her
friends to return to the Isle mouths
back is curved and she can hardly walk
yet somehow she manages to squeeze into
her VK outfit and write a motorcycle
that just doesn't make any sense did you
notice anything we didn't sound off in
the comments we'd love you to join us to
auradon prep will you come sign king bed
we are so excited that you get to go to
Oregon dizzy we totally fell in love
with you in descendants - you're kind
you're smart you're talented and you're
Evie's favorite you deserve so much
better than life on the Isle of the laws
Evie will take great care of you and you
will be so successful in auradon just
keep an eye on your fellow V Ches there
are four new villain kids in descendant
three do you know which BK is totally
obsessed with all things shiny keep
watching for the ten things no one
realized about the new villain kids not
her mother's daughter we meet does eat
remain in descendants - she works at a
super stylish salon on the Isle of the
loss dizzy is the daughter of Jerusalem
mane one of Cinderella's stepsisters in
Cinderella Drusilla is lazy and mean but
dizzy couldn't be more different
she's super sweet and she is such a hard
worker she runs the salon and keeps it
clean she's also talented on making
accessories like the tiara she gave to
EB like father like son two of the Nuvi
kids are actually twins squeaky and
squirmy are the sons of mr. Smee Smee
was the first mate - Captain Hook in
Peter Pan Smee was a total doormat -
hook he did whatever the evil captain
wanted and he was so scared of
everything
[Music]
it's hard to be a pirate if you're timid
squeaky and squirmy are the same way
they're frightened of everything and are
really shy but they have each other at
least daddy's girls
sylia facili a is the doctor of the
voodoo master doctor facili a we saw
just how powerful doctor facili a was in
princess and the frog some of the bee
caves don't want to be like their
parents but Celia really wants to make
her dad proud but that doesn't make her
a villain through and through
what kind of hustle you got going on
with them shiny people no hustle I got
friends on the other side now totally
relates to Celia because she used to
want to make her mom proud even though
Maleficent was evil wicked grandmother
we can all agree that Lady Tremaine was
a terrible stepmother but she was really
good to her daughter's Drizella and
Anastasia however she has not been a
good grandmother she forces dizzy to do
all the cleaning at the salon and home
Lady Tremaine dress is nice but dizzy is
often seen wearing rags and just look at
how tense their relationship is lady
tremaine is obviously better about
losing her servant stepdaughter so she
takes it out on dizzy but that doesn't
mean that she doesn't love dizzy in her
own strange way so excited squeaky and
squirming they look like they're scared
of everything and who can blame them
they've lived their whole life on the
Isle they're really scared of leaving
their dad behind on the Isle of the Lost
but they're still super excited they've
heard lots of stories about Dora Don and
they know life is better there squeaky
and squirmy show us that you can be
scared and excited at the same time what
makes Celia really excited keep watching
to find out southern belle
it might seem like Celia is from the
Isle after all she lived most of her
life there but Celia considers herself
totally southern she says she's from the
south because that's where her dad's
from dr. Priscilla a really lived the
Louisiana culture and that has carried
over to his daughter your heritage
doesn't have to be where you live
tsylia freely honors that Cajun
lifestyle is your heritage different
from where you live
tell us in the comments below big sister
vibes
Dizzy's mom grew up with his sister who
was close in age Drizella and Anastasia
mostly got along but dizzy is an only
child if it wasn't for Evy dizzy would
be super lonely she really feels like
Edie is her big sister Phoebe supports
her and treats our so kindly they have
each other's backs and Edie is the
reason that dizzy gets to go to Oregon
we just love their relationship once
again descendants shows us that you
don't have to be related to be family
biggest fear even though the twins are
excited about Oregon they're really
scared leaving the life you know behind
is terrifying but their biggest fear is
leaving their dad unlike a lot of the
case squeaky and squirmy have a great
relationship with their father and they
are younger than the other BK's they're
afraid that they'll never see their dad
again
the Carlos reassures them that they will
see mr. Smith soon we hope they learn to
be a little less scared living the dream
life on the Isle is pretty rough and
while some of the BK's may enjoy their
life or get along with their parents
dizzy isn't one of them she's dreamed
about living her best life in Oregon
forever in fact most of the BK's have
there's less crime and more happiness in
Oregon dizzy has been waiting her whole
life to get her chance and we just know
that she's awesome enough to succeed
with the chance that Edie gives her
money talks it isn't easy to be rich on
the Isle there are no castles and
everyone is kind of stuck being poor so
it makes sense that Celia is all about
money
life for Celia is about business and
getting rich and she isn't afraid to use
less than legal means to achieve it she
is a skilled pickpocketer we just hope
she learns to clean up her act
which of the Nuvi case is your favorite
let us know in the comments house hoping
you're home ok Audrey you really freaked
us out in descendants 3 we know you lost
your shot at the crown not to mention
your boyfriend but don't worry you don't
have to be the queen of mean to get what
you want we think we speak for everyone
when we say we're glad you put down that
scepter but we have to be honest
you're evil look was a wicked cool
before you judge Audrey there are some
things you need to know about her she's
not your typical villain kid she's a
good princess gone bad gone good again
but here's what nobody realizes about
Audrey in descendants 3 keep watching to
find out who she's teaming up with after
d3 Audrey didn't start out as evil sure
she was a little full of herself and yes
she thought Ben was her property we're
not even sure she loved Ben or if she
was dating him so she could just rule
auradon I was Prince Ben's girlfriend
on the fast track to becoming his wife
in the Queen Audrey was clearly bitter
about Mao stealing everything she ever
wanted but she shocked everyone when she
stole Maleficent sceptre and turned it
into the queen of mean how did this
happen
let's start at the beginning and piece
this thing together at the beginning of
the movie Audrey wasn't planning on
creating a sleep spell that knocked out
all of word on she had just returned
from the salon rested and fresh with a
fabulous new makeover you could see the
look of complete and total shock on her
face when Ben proposed - mal
we watched Audrey's dream of being the
queen of auradon shatter like a glass
slipper
when Audrey broke into the museum she
didn't intend to go full evil she just
wanted to steal the crown did you notice
that she didn't even put the crown on
her head until after she transformed
into evil Audrey she was about to throw
it away but then this
doctor hypnotized her the same way
Maleficent hypnotized Sleeping Beauty
some people thought that Audrey caused
the guard at the front of the museum to
fall asleep but what if it was the
scepter well if it's in scepter beckoned
Audrey into the museum and lured her
into going full villain the scepter
wanted her to take control of it the
magic in that staff was too much for
Audrey to resist
she was under an evil spell which caused
her to cast many additional evil curses
so was it all Audrey's fault keep
watching to find out when Ben and mal
got engaged Audrey didn't only lose out
on the crown she also lost her first
love then was the only boy she's ever
had eyes for she had her future with him
all planned out we know that mal didn't
mean to do it but she took it all away
from Audrey it seemed that Audrey had
everything a princess could won but did
she truly love Ben Audrey was betrothed
to Ben since she was just a little girl
perhaps her grandmother convinced her to
love Ben despite what she really wanted
in Audrey's room there are pictures of
her and then going all the way back to
preschool Audrey was too young to be
able to choose a partner for herself
back then those photos were staged by
Audrey's grandmother who knows if Audrey
would have chosen Ben to be her
boyfriend if she had a choice from the
beginning so who would she choose if it
were up to her we'll get into that a
little bit later it's obvious that
Audrey only wants to make her
grandmother proud in fact every action
Audrey takes in The Descendants movies
is tied to need to please her Grammy
so when Audrey hears her grandmother's
biting words of disapproval after mal
and Ben's engagement it cuts her to her
core all she ever wanted was to make her
Grammy proud our family's status gone
Queen Leah's expectations of Audrey were
impossible to achieve
Audrey reached her breaking point when
she learned she would never be the queen
of auradon that's when she found herself
the queen of mean underneath all of that
pink hair and distressed leather was
just a little girl who needed the
unconditional love and approval of her
grandmother instead her grandmother
slapped her with that cruel comment that
Audrey's mother could hold on to a
prince in her sleep now we see where
Audrey learned to be so mean
now here's the really mind-blowing thing
that nobody gets about Audrey if it
wasn't for her the barrier would have
never been opened
Audrey's evil deeds became the catalyst
for change in auradon allow us to
explain before Audrey stole the crown
and the scepter another villain was
stirring up trouble that's right we're
talking about Hades after he pushed his
way through the barrier and almost stole
all of Mel's powers everyone in auradon
was terrified they wanted to close the
barrier for good and it was all Mao's
idea which was a total whoa moment for
fans I think that we have to close
barrier forever
if Audrey hadn't stolen the crown and
scepter put asleep and stones fell on
everyone and turned Ben into a beast now
would have learned nothing
instead mal came to realize that there
is both good and evil in everyone that
realization is what made mal decide to
take down the barrier for good so thanks
Audrey thankfully when Audrey woke from
her deep sleep she was back to her old
self again alas she was still without a
prince on her arm but don't feel bad for
her
from the sparks flying between Audrey
and Harry we think the pirate's life
might be right for Audrey so what's your
verdict is Audrey mean or misunderstood
sound off in the comments come on mal
get the gang back together for one more
movie ah no I'm in charge we don't know
what we're going to do after the end at
descendants three so tell evj Audrey and
the rest of the crew to make descendants
for happened if this is the end of an
era we are not ready if we could use one
magic spell from your spell book we
would wish for d4 to become a reality if
we need a little magic to keep this
going it's just sometimes for happening
it's not likely that means the cast may
officially be hanging up there villain
kit outfits for good but fans are still
holding out hope that Disney will decide
to go forward with the fourth film it's
time that we take the barrier down
forever here's everything we know
the program is shut down you didn't
think this was the end of the story did
you well for descendants it just might
be with the recent tragic events and
several new developments there's a good
possibility that descendants or is a
wish that will never come true
I'm sorry I just I thought that I was
afraid to tell me that means d3 will be
Disney Channel's final film for the
franchise here's everything we've been
able to find out about the fate of
descendants for the descendants director
is the first to confirm our suspicions
about d4 Kenny Ortega Kenny Ortega is
the genius behind descendants 1 2 & 3 as
well as the High School Musical movies
it would be nearly impossible for Disney
to move on to descendants or without
Kenny and at the helm as director so
when he took to Instagram to write a
post thanking fans all over the world
for sharing in their descendants dreams
it seemed like a farewell you wrote that
the fans help make their dreams come
true the video with this heartfelt
caption showed a behind-the-scenes video
of the descendant 3 cast rehearsing for
the movie it seemed like his final
goodbyes to the possibility of
descendants for we all know that they
lost an irreplaceable cast member so how
would they move forward after such a
heartbreaking blow additionally Kenny
was discussing the possibility of a High
School Musical 4 in the future it would
be hard for him to focus on descendants
for if he was going to be working on a
new High School Musical 4 Disney this is
a pretty good indicator that d4 is not
happening new and upcoming projects for
the cast of d3 ever since production
wrapped on descendents 3 the original
cast has been super busy it appears as
though no one is clearing their
calendars to make room for descendants 4
for instance according to Jay 14 there
is a rumor going around that dove
Cameron may star in a movie based on the
Broadway musical Wicked
she would make an amazing Glinda however
if dove takes that role she'll be too
busy to even consider doing another
descendants film it also seems that two
of Cameron has taken a break from the
small screen to follow her passion in
theatre she has recently starred in
clueless on Broadway and lie
in the Piazza in London with all of that
action it would be hard for this
Broadway Beauty to pull herself away and
put on that purple wig for descendants
for on the final day of filming
descendants three dub posted something
on her Instagram that suggests it's
truly the end of an era she posted a pic
of the core for villain kids hands
underneath the pic was a handwritten
note that read dear diary today is the
last day of descendants
maybe dub knew all along that this was
the end just like her co-star Sophia
Carson is not slowing down anytime soon
she is currently in production filming a
new Netflix movie about dance
it's called feel the beat does that mean
Sofia is hanging up her long blue wig
for good the idea that we may never see
Evie again on the small screen after d3
is just too depressing
Sofia officially said goodbye to her
character Edie on Instagram she posted a
picture of her with dub booboo and
Cameron the caption read dear world
today is a wrap on descendants three
there will never ever be enough words
she thanked the fans from the bottom of
her heart then really kicked us in the
fields when she wrote that they will
forever be our Evie now Jay and Carlos
that seems pretty final doesn't it it
appears that booboo Stewart is also not
clearing his schedule for descendants
forward he has starred in a string of
films and TV shows since production
wrapped on descendants three most
notably he's playing the role of Vic
Lakota in the upcoming TV series
Paradise City with the series set to air
later this year booboo probably won't
have much time for another descendants
movie he hasn't mentioned The
Descendants movies very much at all on
social media maybe it's too painful for
him to say goodbye the barrier will come
down as of right now it's not likely
that we're going to see another
descendants movie after number three but
you never know the last high school
musical came out in 2008 now 11 years
later Kenny Ortega is entertaining the
idea of doing a High School Musical 4
that's a good indicator that descendants
4 may still have a shot we just hope
they don't wait until 2030 to make it
happen what do you guys think will
Disney make a descendants or sometime in
the
future let us know in the comments give
this video a big thumbs up if you want
to see descendants or happen as much as
we do and subscribe to our channel to
stay up to date with our latest videos
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]